this is exclusive video of Elon giving a
lecture at the home he used to own in
Bel Air
regular schools were doing a good enough
job of preparing kids
does anybody have any experience with
first principles analysis do you know
what it means
he's a big proponent of teaching people
to think based on first principles which
is figuring out how things work by
boiling them down to the basics for
example it used to be that people
thought a radical Improvement in
rocketry was impossible space agencies
and private companies tried to build
reusable Rockets but failed the only one
that kind of worked was NASA's Space
Shuttle but the cost of refurbishing the
boosters by fishing them out of the
ocean was so great that it didn't make
sense you look at what I was doing say
well others did others didn't make it
works therefore it doesn't work but that
that has no basis in reality
um okay both principles of foundational
approach would be to say let's look at
the physics and economics
um of a rocket and say if we do if we do
if we can analyze the physics
of the rocket is it physically possible
first principles thinking would break
down the cost of the Rockets materials
and figure out how to reassemble the
materials to produce a more affordable
rocket which is spacex's Mission at
Astro School originally began out of
spacex's Rocket Factory in Hawthorne
California to teach elon's children and
the kids of stem employees then it moved
to his house for a couple of years the
one that formerly belonged to Gene
Wilder Elon was a guest lecturer the
teacher who helped create the curriculum
was Josh Dunn hey Josh hey Cindy Don
taught one of elon's sons at a private
school for gifted children in La the
SpaceX CEO then approached him to start
experimental school at his rocket
Factory so if elon's directive was to
make it great then okay well
what is what does great look like it
looked like a totally different
experience than a typical School
instead of classes in languages music or
sports kids focused on critical thinking
solving the types of problems SpaceX
employees tackle like imagine how the
grid fin could be redesigned he's
referring to the fins that come down
when the Falcon 9 lands could you
imagine other designs and how would you
even know if those designs would be more
efficacious than the design that's
currently being used the lesson of first
principles is to not be bound by what's
already been done you don't have to
create grid fins of the same design size
or material
you can even go back to the drawing
board completely and imagine something
totally different that could direct a
descending rocket can something other
than grid fins be better for the
successor to the Falcon 9 Starship
there were also questions related to
Tesla as students had exposure to
Tesla's Design Studio within spacex's
Hawthorne Factory for example like what
could the supercharger Network look like
in a country where it doesn't yet exist
so what if you created the supercharger
Network in Argentina there are many
different ways to answer this question
what Josh was looking for was the
ability to reason centering
superchargers around dense populations
is a start and then the next question is
like where do we go next and the way
that they reason through that is really
interesting because then they're seeing
these like multiple Pathways that they
could they could approach and one of the
ways that you can help them is limit the
number of superchargers that they could
build so if you could only build you
know 50 superchargers in the country of
Argentina for that first year where were
those 50b and this is high level
thinking at a really young age it's a
remarkable what kids are capable of when
you give them opportunities where they
have decisions to make Josh now runs
synthesis an online program applying the
same type of thinking at Elon school oh
my gosh this is the best place
we're going really fast
students from around the world
strategize in teams as a way to mirror
collaboration in real life
we'll start the first game in about five
minutes although the students are as
young as eight the problems they have to
answer are difficult even for adults for
example imagine that rocket travel is as
normal as plane travel if you had to
choose one future which would it be
traveling to anywhere on Earth within an
hour going sightseeing on the moon or
three starting a city on Mars again
there's no right or wrong answer but the
idea is to start wondering like well
which will come first and which one will
change human life on here on on Earth
most it's about figuring out what the
future will look like and then building
that future
in the way that Tesla is looking to
disrupt transportation and SpaceX the
rocket industry Elon is reimagining the
future of Education although his
original private school is no longer
running he's opened up another Ad Astra
school at spacex's Star Base in Texas
with a few dozen students well this type
of education produce the next great
entrepreneur
there are many ways to learn that can be
more effective than sitting in a
classroom my sponsor brilliant is a
website and app where you can improve
your science math and computer science
skills by learning interactively their
puzzles are for people of all ages and
experiences whether you're studying or
if you're already working I use
brilliant to improve my critical
thinking skills by going through their
logic courses
brilliant has sponsored my videos since
I started newsthink in 2020 and I've
noticed my viewers especially love their
computer science fundamentals course
where you can wrap your mind around
computational thinking and no coding is
required their scientific thinking
course is also really popular with my
viewers you can explore the laws of
physics and principles of engineering
and learn the rules as you play if
you're ever stuck you can view the
explanation to understand where you went
wrong brilliant is free for you to try
out by going to the custom link in my
description
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 people to sign up with my link will
get 20 off the annual premium
subscription which unlocks all of the
courses on brilliant